you open your book with a few lines from
a poem by
jorge luis borges a love poem i'm gonna
read parts of it because it's a damn
good poem yeah it's called two english
poems i mean there's i'd like to
understand why you used it
and the specific parts you used which is
interesting but then when i read the
full thing
so i think you used it
as as a as a sort of beautiful
description of what it means to delve
deep into understanding
uh offering yourself to the task of
understanding another human being but if
you look at the full context of the poem
it's also a damn good description of
being hit by love and overtaken by it
and uh
uh sort of
and trying to
trying to figure out how to make sense
of the world now that you've been uh
stricken by it
it says a bunch of things
uh about
chatting and significantly with friends
and all those kinds of things and then
the poem reads
the big wave brought you
i get this is the moment
i guess of the universe where the two
people you fall in love maybe i'm
totally misreading this poem by the way
it doesn't matter you can't misread a
poem
so it goes on words any words you're
laughter and you're so lazily and
incessantly beautiful
we talked and you have forgotten the
words
the shattering dawn finds me in a
deserted street of my city your profile
turned away the sounds that go to make
your name
the lilt of your laughter these are the
illustrious toys you have left me so
these little memories of these peculiar
little details he remembers those are
the illustrious toys
i apologize to mix my own words of the
poem but you should definitely read it
i turn them over in the dawn i lose them
i find them i tell them to the few
straight dogs into the few stray stars
of the dawn
your dark
rich
life
i must get at you somehow
i put away those illustrious toys you
have left me i want your hidden look
your real smile that lonely mocking
smile your cool mirror knows
i want your hidden look your real smile
i am so i this is the first part of the
poem and then it goes on which is some
of the parts that you reference
second part is what can i hold you with
i offer you lean streets desperate
sunsets the moon of the jagged suburbs i
offer you the bitterness of a man who
has looked long and long in a lonely
moon
i offer you my ancestors my dead men the
ghosts the living men have honored in
bronze my father's father killed in the
frontier of buenos aires two bullets
through his lungs and so on so on i
offer you whatever insights my books may
hold whatever manliness of humor my life
i offer you the loyalty of a man who has
never been loyal i offer you that kernel
of myself that have saved somehow the
central heart that deals not in words
traffics
not with dreams and is untouched by time
my joy and
adversities
and i think this is where the part they
include in the book
i offer you the memory of a yellow rose
seen at sunset
years before you were born
i
damn that's a good line okay
[Laughter]
i offer you explanations of yourself
theories about yourself authentic and
surprising news of yourself i can give
you my loneliness my darkness the hunger
of my heart i am trying to bribe you
with uncertainty with danger with defeat
that is a man who's in love and longing
if i've taken but i just want to go back
to maybe you could say why you want to
include that poem but also
your dark rich life i must get at you
somehow i put away those illustrious
toys you have left me out when you're i
want your hidden look your real smile
that lonely mocking smile your cool
mirror knows what sometimes i meet a
stranger
and i just
it's like it's like a double take
it's like who are you
have we met before somewhere who's that
person behind there
and i want to get at that whatever that
is and of course maybe that's what love
is because maybe
uh maybe that's the whole pursuit like a
lifelong pursuit of getting at that
person maybe that's what that is and
like that uh insatiable sort of
curiosity to keep getting like well
who's that person in your own private
life yeah so that absolutely i think
that it was a beautiful description of
what you just said when there's that
first moment
and then you want to dive deeper you
want to know what the what the hidden
mysteries are
in a way it's it's a it's a love poem
as a as a scientist though it also
it's a bit of how a scientist can love
science and and
that
wanting to to dive deeper is
it's almost like again where the it
could be a love affair with
investigating the human mind for example
and and that was one reason it spoke to
me also again thinking about
the broader sweep of where the human
mind came from uh
the steps it took
to get where it is today what was given
up along the way what compromises were
made and here's where the darkness of
the poem starts to come in a little bit
too it doesn't shy away
from the negativity
from
the confusion from the danger
and then at the very end
the board faces offering up
scenes from his life parts of himself
and this is how we connect with people
we offer up parts of ourselves just here
it is and then we see how well does that
map on to what you have and it's it's
that offering up
that i liked and not not the good stuff
or not only the good stuff the yellow
rose is nice but but he's offering up
the bad stuff too
and that that to me was important for
the for the book because
i'm offering up hard stuff too and in
fact a lot of it and also hard stuff
from within me from my my own personal
side too and that was there's a lot of
vulnerability that comes with that but
that's
that comes with love that comes with
writing you have to be open you have to
be vulnerable and so
i thought that reflected what i was
trying to do and i thought it was a as
an epigraph it kind of made it clear
uh how vulnerable
i was in taking this step but also
what what could come out of it and also
in a meta way because i was not familiar
with this poem
it uh
it made me curious
of the poem itself to pull at that
thread of finding out more
see you picked a very particular part
that kind of made you want to um
pull at that thread and and
and see where did this where did these
few lines come from
because i i read it as a curiosity of a
scientist those lines
alone and also
as a desperate
uh human being
searching like offering himself for an
understanding or connection with with
another human being and then because i
wasn't sure if it's a love poem or not
or if it's desperation or if it's
curious whatever it is and then you see
the love poem i mean i don't know that
that's gonna stick with me for a while
the
your dark rich life
and then a few lines in here are just
i mean those are i'm going to just use
them as
pickup lines at a bar
i offer you the memory of a yellow rose
seen at sunset years before you were
born
now that's a pickup line i've never
heard if if i've ever heard one anyway
sorry but this is universal you know you
see it in so many forms of of art you
know like you know we're in texas now
you see this in country uh country and
western songs it's it's often a list of
things like here's how i describe myself
there's this and there's that and
there's the other thing and here you are
these things matter to me and i hope
they matter to you too it's a it's a
pretty universal form but it's but he
did it in this very artful uh
and very
vulnerable way it was it was both both
beautiful and you could you could feel
the hurt coming from him too and that
was important
the dark stuff too i offer you my
ancestors my dead men the ghosts that
living men have honored in bronze and
talking about two bullets through his
lungs bearded and dead
wrapped by his
soldiers in the height of a cow my
mother's grandfather just 24 heading a
charge of 300 men in peru now ghosts
on vanished horses
so all of it the whole history of it
you